[Musik]
heute kurz zwei wichtige dinge bevor es
losgeht mir ist gerade aufgefallen
dieser praxis absolut scheiße in der
kamera sieht man das jetzt
wahrscheinlich nicht so gut aber meine
haare sind ebels verklebt und nass
dadurch keine ahnung habe ich für sechs
euro in paris gekauft nicht zu empfehlen
zweite sache ist meine langjährige
kamera die ich schon meine ganze youtube
laufbahn habe das ist immer noch eine
canon eos 600d mit dem eigentlich ganz
cool objektiv gibt glaube ich so langsam
den geist auf die wird irgendwie immer
langsamer und das sd karten lesegerät
darin ist irgendwie nicht mehr so ganz
fehlt manchmal wird die sd karte nämlich
überhaupt nicht gelesen oder als
schreibgeschützt identifiziert obwohl
sie es gar nicht ist deswegen schreibt
mir noch mal gerne in die kommentare was
für kameras dem cool einfach um solar
videos zu drehen am liebsten von kindern
natürlich ich habe glaube ich anerkennen
er aus 80 d gedacht also am besten
nichts was über 1000 euro kostet hey was
geht ab und damit herzlich willkommen
bei einem neuen video ich hoffe
natürlich euch geht's gut heute mit
einem kleinen lager video und zwar frage
mich immer mehr leute ja alex wann kommt
eigentlich der dritte teil von iphone
nähe von büroklammern zum iphone hoch
tausch also unter diesem titel habe ich
das ja gestartet falls ihr das nicht
gesehen habt hier vielleicht man ganz
kurzer ausschnitt leute werden es gerade
erklärt dass wir einen shared vielleicht
bekommen aber er guckt
also ich bin all gestartet mit einer
büroklammer ich habe das ganze in
amerika irgendwie mal gesehen und wollte
mich damit hoch tauschen so weit wie es
geht ich habe mir das viel leichter
vorgestellt also es ist das hat man
jetzt auch im zweiten video schon
gesehen ich habe bestimmt ich habe ja
gar nicht alle leute eingestellt aber
ich habe bestimmt 25 leute gefragt ob
die irgendwas haben bis wir dann
irgendwann im leben store waren und der
verkäufer war so freundlich und hat
diese iphone hülle die ich hatte gegen
ein t shirt getauscht und zwar handelt
es sich dabei um dieses shirt von der
kollaboration mit justin timberlake das
coole war als ich das getauscht habe
oder er tauscht hat war das noch gar
nicht im shop zu kaufen es ist auch noch
komplett neu hier sieht man das ja wir
haben das in der größe m
also das ist das letzte was ich halt
jetzt gerade hab ich habe wirklich lange
hin und her überlegt ob ich jetzt schon
damit aufhören soll oder ob ich noch
weitermachen soll kurze story noch also
ich habe natürlich versucht weiter zu
tauschen
das ding ist du findest in der stadt
wirklich absolut niemanden der plötzlich
bereit ist irgendwas gegen seinen
t-shirts zu tauschen obwohl das t shirt
der wirklich coole die meisten leute
halten wir dann irgendwie in der hin-
oder zigaretten oder wir keine ahnung
weil niemand hat wirklich etwas
gleichwertiges oder oder was er bereit
ist was eventuell sogar höheren wert hat
als dieses t shirt so was halt die
wenigsten dabei und tauschen ist dann
ist ja auch logisch ich meine das meiste
hat jahren wirklichen wert für einen
selber dann keine ahnung und einfach
irgendwelche shops reinzugehen und den
zu sagen hier bin mit kamera unterwegs
tauschen irgendwas gegen dieses t shirt
das machen auch wirklich die wenigsten
also da hatten wir wirklich glück bei
leber ist dass die das gemacht haben
auch nochmal an dieser stelle schöne
grüße dann haben ja auch leute
geschrieben
ich glaube am sinnvollsten wäre es wenn
du einfach von tür zu tür gehst dort
klinge ist weil da haben die leute ja
alles zu hause alles mögliche zum teil
das problem ist das möchte ich nicht
machen einfach aus dem grund gut wenn da
jetzt jemand wohnt der keine ahnung
irgendwie ein t shirt von mir bestellt
hat oder der mich kennt dann kriege ich
das sehr gerne und schaute vorbei
stellt euch mal vor zu euch nach hause
wird irgendein typ kommen dass film der
irgendwas tauschen will also da komme
ich mir total schlecht bevor und da habe
ich gesagt okay das geht mir dann auch
zu weit dann lasse ich erst mal ich bin
jetzt allerdings auf die idee gekommen
dass trotzdem weiter zu führen und dafür
brauche ich ganz dringend eure
unterstützung aber ich kann mir auch
vorstellen dass das wirklich richtig
cool wird vor allem für diejenigen die
dann
ja vielleicht irgendwas zum tauschen
parat haben also hier nochmal das t
shirt ist 30 euro wert von der mark
webber ist also ich sag immer jeweils
dazu ich hoffe das ist richtig
kollaboration mit justin timberlake wie
gesagt 30 euro wert komplett neu in
größe m person jetzt aufpassen wenn du
da draußen sagt das hätte ich gerne und
mir fällt auch direkt was ein was ich
dagegen tauschen würde dann schreib mir
bitte einfach den gegenstand über
instagram auf instagram sich alex wie
jack das einfach mal ab und ich lese mir
dann die ganzen nachrichten durch und
hoffentlich ist jemand dabei wo ich sage
das möchte ich gerne gegen das t shirt
tauschen natürlich will ich auch nur
sachen tauschen die ich selber cool
finde also nicht irgendwas was mir
selber nicht gefällt ihr könnt mir
einfach mal schreiben und wenn ihr glück
habt schreibe ich euch dann zurück und
dann können wir es entweder so machen
dass er hier nach köln vom zu mir ich
kann euch am bahnhof abholen oder so
dann machen wir keine ahnung mehr was
essen tauschen das t shirt gegen
irgendwas anderes oder eventuell komme
ich auch zu euch nach hause wenn ich
jetzt nicht in österreich wohnt am
besten wäre es natürlich wenn ihr aus
nordrhein westfalen kommt oder so ich
wurde ja auch hier in köln dann kann man
sich glaube ich ganz easy mal treffen
und dann drehe ich halt immer so teile
oder so aus städte wo ich mich mit
jemandem von euch treffen nehmen es mit
ins video und so soll diese videoreihe
dann halt weitergehen ich meine so hat
das noch niemand gemacht über seine
youtube community irgendwas hoch zu
tauschen und ich bin einfach mal
gespannt was dann passieren wird also
ich will euch mega freuen wenn möglichst
viele von euch mir schreiben würden über
instagram ich kündige das auch noch mal
in meiner ins astoria und dann schauen
wir einfach mal was wir rausholen können
weil ich finde jede immer noch richtig
geil da raushalten format zu machen
eine büroklammer hoch zu tauschen habe
ich auch noch nicht so wirklich gesehen
wo es dann wirklich so etwas kommt was
wirklich in höheren wert hat und ja
deswegen brauche ich eure hilfe
schreibt mir gerne das war es auch schon
mit diesem eher kürzeren informations
video von mir also hier nochmal das t
shirt in größe m
richtig geil können jungs und mädchen
tragen meldet euch bei mir wenn ihr das
haben wollte und schreibt mir euren
gegenstand was sie tauschen würde dann
machen wir uns einen coolen vormittag
oder so hier in köln und ja ich hoffe
ihr habt doch darauf und feiert die
ideen und wir sehen uns morgen oder
übermorgen wieder
ich wünsche euch noch einen angenehmen
tag